I'm Katie and it took me 19 years to
figure out that I had Lyme disease I'd
always had health issues my whole life
from when I was young sinus problems
poor immune system it was my freshman
year of college I kept getting pneumonia
like every week or two and then all of a
sudden it was like 20 hours a day of
sleep or I couldn't get up to move I
felt so out of control I stopped going
to my classes because when I was at my
classes I couldn't really process the
information I wasn't hearing the
questions I wasn't able to keep up with
the reading there was just something
missing
[Music]
there was no specific note that the
doctor at Washington and Lee could give
me because she didn't know what was
wrong either I had to go through at
least 15 doctors
it started with pneumonia walking
pneumonia chronic walking pneumonia
epstein-barr virus mono fibromyalgia
pots chronic fatigue syndrome
generalized anxiety disorder and
depression
I didn't know what it could be so then
having someone say you need to see a
psychiatrist it was half [ __ ] you know
but also okay this man has eight degrees
on his wall and I certainly doubted in
moments that I was making everything I
was experiencing up they made me feel
like I wanted attention I thought I was
going to die his suicidal thoughts crept
in I really think that what kept me
going was wanting to see where the
mystery went I wanted the answer and I
kind of never lost sight that that I
would receive that eventually and that I
would prove somebody wrong I'm stubborn
I'm real stubborn it wasn't officially
until a sports masseuse who was working
on my body and you know hearing all of
my trials and tribulations said have you
looked into this I hear it's very hard
to diagnose and you have to be very firm
with doctors in order to get them to
test for it
I was like okay here we go and I went
and I found any doctor that would take
it seriously
one of whom diagnosed me and the other
of whom treated me and my doctor who was
taking this very seriously held my hand
for the first time since I had gotten
sick and said this is not easy and this
is not straightforward but I'm gonna try
really hard and we're gonna figure this
out for you that moment of this is what
you have you have a name you can write
this down on your paperwork
you can tell this to loved ones we have
a path and maybe it's not super clear
and we're gonna have to switch around
your medications a lot but you have this
thing and you have not been crazy this
whole time it was a stunning moment it
gave me the fuel that I needed to go
forward with treatment for over a year
with intensity I would be throwing up so
much have no appetite and look like
complete [ __ ] and I would just smile so
much because I knew that the medication
that was making me sick was doing
something and that's why I was getting
sick and it was this this whole process
in my brain like a challenge like I was
fighting these bugs that were in my body
having a goal versus just going down and
down and thinking that you're crazy
they're incomparable and it gets easier
the further I get away from my former
self because letting go of her has been
very difficult hearing from doctors and
hearing from loved ones is always
reassuring and getting an answer or
getting support is what we all want but
no one will ever ever ever know what's
going on inside of your body are going
on inside of your brain unless you tell
them and in order to tell them
confidently
you have to have been listening to
yourself anything that seems abnormal to
you listen to it and remind yourself
that you are worth paying attention to
yourself and if you don't understand and
believe yourself no one else will
[Music]